there's a lot of weird debates about
public land too here's one that really
gets me there's a lot of people that are
really into public land and they were
there with public land is super
important to them they want they only
want to hunt public land but they have
secret spots on public land they don't
want anybody know about them and if you
tell someone about their spot on public
land they'll get mad at you
like if you take someone to a spot I've
heard Rinella talked about this on his
show like he's a big public land guy
yeah but he'll talk on his show about
what a betrayal it is if you tell a
person about a spot and they tell
someone else else about that spot you
know they go to that spot without you
what the [ __ ] are you talking about is
this public land or is it not and if
it's not if it is public land if you're
telling someone about a spot you're
telling me that this public land spot
you don't want them going to without you
not unless they find it on their own
that is [ __ ] ridiculous right that's
ridiculous that's like it's but yeah if
you have a private spot on public land
so you're a public land guy until it
infringes on your own privacy like you
figured out a way to have a private spot
on public land and if you share this
private spot with someone else they're
not allowed to go there without you [ __ ]
you that's crazy dude this is the number
one rule in fishing to someone take [ __ ]
or it's not yeah but if someone takes
you to a sweet little spot where they
just rip lips constantly on on a lake
and then next thing you know they go out
there on a weekend and you're sitting
there in your boat with a bunch of
buddies
that's stupid this is like bro I took
you to my spot oh they're [ __ ]
that's stupid I don't think so you think
they should not go there
I think there's do you think they own
that spot it's no [ __ ] joke they
don't own it okay they don't own it
let's let's talk about like Lake
Superior
okay we've got a giant ass lake yep and
someone has a spot where all the lake
trout live a little reef yeah yeah where
everything's chilling and tell me about
that spot and then you go back there six
months later and I'm at that spot you're
gonna be mad at me no probably not not
me but if it's a guy
they don't know as well if I went back
and you had a whole bunch of guys there
would be like dude you should have saved
this before that's ridiculous
it's a [ __ ] public leg not taking you
in any my spot see this is the thing
this these people that say they want
everything to be public that's not
public it's not public if you don't want
other people going back there I see the
argument though because he put in the
work to find a good place that took work
within public land and you better not
tell people about it or they're gonna go
back yeah that's well that's where that
you go wrong
yeah if you find it you gotta just you
got to just keep it quiet that's so
corny
that's so ridiculous like do you want
that spot to yourself you want that spot
to be private in a way yeah you do yeah
you're making a private area in public
land that's what you're doing yep I
think that's preposterous well could you
imagine if you say you were going elk
hunting you left camp an hour and a half
before daylight and you pack all the way
out there and there's someone sitting on
your glassing Rock in that Basin it's
not yours but you would still say I wish
I never told this guy land all right
someone got there first no one's ever
even tell you about their spot this is a
spot that's been the same way for
hundreds of thousands of years it had
way it has but someone found it put in
the work to find it this is some
small-minded thinking man yep this is
some small-minded thinking I know sorry
but this is a common way of thinking I
would say I'd say there's people that
don't think that way but there's
certainly people that are I would have
to side with with Rinella on that really
yeah so you think so let me ask you this
so if you if someone takes you to a
place and it's this really good mule
deer spot and you got a you hike in
seven miles and this is beautiful basin
and you go there and it's just to always
deer there you don't go there without
that person's from me I would tell I
would say are you gonna be there and if
he said no and I'd say can I go I
wouldn't take why that would be carried
because they go to national forest land
can I go to public land can I go to this
body you don't [ __ ] own even a little
bit out of respect for that guy that
found it found it you just walked he
walked on the dirt found what a tree
there's more tree
yeah this is crazy this is my rock I
stand on this top two cliff is my cliff
that's crazy yeah I mean you can take it
to a point but crazy I still think it's
code
it's a weird code the other argument
though too is just from a hunting
situation say me as a person who doesn't
hunt I've heard it so I you concept me
but I'm trying to compare it to
something else like if it was a
basketball hoop I found somewhere now
don't tell somebody to go to that
playground because it's my hoop and I
show up at people are there playing
public league refine another hoop to
play on well you don't play basketball
that it seems it seems ridiculous but
I'm just trying to thank you that you
like you have especially in today's day
and age because today people use like
onyx maps and they use Google Earth and
you you could find these beautiful spots
and you just go out to them like if you
find a beautiful spot on Google Earth
and you go out to it and you go hey man
this is a spot I found don't Golder
those much but this is my spot on public
land seems ridiculous yeah it does it
does but there I think there's a
legitimate code to it it seems
ridiculous but it seems understandable
that someone be upset if they're looking
forward to going to a place and they
told you about it a year ago and they go
to that place they hi Kim take some 9
miles yeah and you're there yeah tough
[ __ ] go another 9 she got there earlier
you procrastinating [ __ ] I'm
taking you with me when we're going to
someone's spot the fella you don't know
one owns any spots see that's what's so
weird about it to me it's it's there
there definitely is a there definitely
is a line I mean I I see your argument a
hundred percent and I know it you know
at some point it it it could definitely
get childish or out of hand I mean
obviously there's a ton of ton of stuff
put out a courtesy yeah I mean if any
time you showed me something cool if
you're like hey I got this cool thing
it's what I do
you know it's kind of private take my
family there whatever I'd be like yeah I
respect that but it's not private that's
what's weird
yeah what's we write the whole waters
under public land but fishermen would be
the same right but it's the chapped and
still crazy captains it is the thing
about public land is that it's supposed
to be everyone's so if you find a really
good area in public land that's supposed
to be available for everyone you know
that's not what everybody wants when
everybody wants that's one of the things
about people not wanting new people to
get into hunting like I've heard this
argument before like you shouldn't be
telling people to get into hunting
because it's already tough tough enough
out there on public land has already so
many people hunting on public land if
more people get into hunting who's gonna
be more pressure like what yeah that's
that's not me
I'm definitely looking to get more
people in for sure right because you're
thinking they don't know about your
spots I'll find a new spot that's a good
attitude